hey guys right before the pandemic
struck
julia and i made a very special episode
we're excited to finally share with you
we visited a financial therapist to
discuss
a challenge we've struggled with for
years now if we did this today we'd
probably do it outdoors
with masks and have a lot of different
issues to talk about but we still think
it's relevant to consider how your
emotional history
impacts your financial decision making
and spoiler alert
i get a little weeping julia and i have
worked professionally as financial
advisors for many years
over that time we've helped a lot of
clients expanded our knowledge base and
started a popular youtube show
but one thing we've never done is raise
our fees that's right
nervous newbie julia and phillip charge
the same rates as experienced
confident julia and philip we've talked
about it for a long time but it just
feels so
weird like i think we're worth it but
for some reason it's really scary to
pull that trigger
so on this special episode of two cents
we've decided to turn the tables
and get help from someone else oh and
you can lose the background we won't be
needing that
we're here at the office of michelle
bowles a therapist who specializes in
the emotions that money can cause in
people's lives
i'll admit i'm a little nervous i mean
i'd like to think that we're pretty
financially savvy but you never know
what can come up once you start digging
just remember whatever happens is
between you me and the therapist
right and our hundreds of thousands of
subscribers
good point let's go inside
hi i'm michelle i'm julia well thank you
so much
for having us here today michelle we are
excited and
nervous so what is it
you actually do well so i'm a financial
therapist specifically helping couples
work with money in the relationship and
a financial therapist
is not a financial person that's gonna
sit down with your bills or your budget
or tell you what to do with your money
but really looking at
the belief systems that you're bringing
in about the money
and why you as a couple might get stuck
on particular
decisions do you find my dad was a cpa
my parents were both very poor i just
naturally gravitated towards
understanding money but then see seeing
couples and money such a
typical issue for couples and it can be
hard to talk about
because there's this idea of you know
it's not polite topic
in lower socioeconomic circles
or middle class but the upper class the
one percent
will talk about money quite comfortably
and with their children
and they'll educate them about money
and so a lot of us come out into the
world without
the information we need about money
okay so michelle what should we expect
as we go into this session we've never
been
in a financial therapy session before um
i can tell you i don't know what to
expect because i've never been in a
therapy session with the two of you
before
so we're all kind of in as it together
and all i can tell you is we all get
stuck and it's just really do you have a
few tools to get unstuck we're excited
yeah i think we're ready okay great well
let's start then
well money gets to the heart of our
sense of safety it's often
associated with different types of
threats it's either threatening to make
it
it's threatening to spend it or it's
threatening to save it
and there's all kinds of things that we
do to avoid feeling those fears that are
connected
to money so when i think about raising
our fee
i worry like we'll just be for rich
people
i don't want to be you worry that
by raising our fees we won't be able to
help as many people
is that right yes and just see if you
can remember anything
from your history where you started to
get the idea that some people have money
and some people
don't have money and that
something is nefarious about it
yeah i think this is kind of random
why i think of this but i remember
growing up my dad he was a used car
salesman
he one year won a trip to hawaii
because he was such a great salesperson
and his boss took it from him
the owner of this big car
dealership who had all the money that he
could have possibly wanted
he took that that vacation from my dad
so when i think about that man the story
i make up about him
is
i think the story that i make up about
that man is that
his wealth made him
blind to the needs of others
i remember how mad my mother was my
mom was she wasn't mad about the loss of
this trip she was
mad about how poorly he'd been treated
when we see that other people have money
or don't have money
that also generates a lot of feelings in
us
we can feel greedy like we need more
we can feel deprived like we don't have
enough we can feel ashamed
of what we have we can feel
envy for what they have so really money
is a very emotional topic for all of us
when i think about raising our fees i
have a couple feelings
one of them is
a feeling of being corrupt
i i mean i'm really worried of what
people will think of us
even talking about it not even doing it
maybe are you worried about like our
fans and our subscribers thinking like
yeah and yeah and what the story make up
is that they will think
the story i make up is they will think
we are
predatory and frauds
i definitely started to feel some
changes in how i was thinking about
ideas of integrity and corruption saying
how we feel about this together and
with somebody else in the room just kind
of made it
less intimidating less shameful when i
first became a financial advisor my
first job i saw
advisors who were older than me doing
things
and selling things that
to my mind look like they only helped
out the advisor
and didn't help out the person on the
other end and do you now think that
this is equivalent to doing that
it could be could be could be good
all of our stories come from our history
that we really can't
come from anywhere but our own
experiences i mean we have an
imagination but
when it comes to emotional things it's
usually from our memory our memory
networks
the stories that our minds make up we
call those projections
and when your past creates projections
that blocks connection for the couple
when i was younger i was really into
literature
and loved to read the classics and
so many stories the evil corrupt
character is the wealthy one
it was part of the reason i decided to
become an artist and
study art in school was that seemed like
the exact opposite direction
i knew i'd be poor but but true to
myself
if i ran away from a lucrative career
it's a very primitive fear if we're all
living in a village right and i'm
hoarding food and water
while you're starving you're gonna come
kill me
and that's really th that was the
correct response that's how
some of our ancestors got here so
understanding that when we have
more there is there is a threat level
you know
to um to having more when other people
don't have
but especially if we saw anyone get hurt
by that dynamic as a child as an adult
when i look at that decision
i have a hard time trusting myself i
trust you
i i trust you more than i trust myself
when i see you being decisive i feel
more confident and what comes up from me
hearing you say that
when i hear you say that
um it worries me
i i get a little anxious about whether i
am
making right decisions so in those
moments what i might need from you
in those moments what i might need from
you is to hear
that it it'll be okay if i don't make
the best choice sometimes
that if i make a mistake that
you can still trust me i actually did
actually find it quite surprising that
we were looking at each other
that she was not giving us advice to you
know to do this or don't do this because
that's what an
advisor does i would say she created a
safe emotional place to talk about
non-safe
ideas working with julie and philip in
that session i'm i'm noticing okay
there's like a lot of strengths here
they're
able to listen to each other be curious
whichever way they decide to go i know
that their relationship's better
for having learned where some of the
energy was coming from
yay thank you thank you very very much
thank you michelle
because of our work philip and i are
already pretty used to discussing money
issues
openly with each other but most couples
struggle to get on the same financial
page
you might disagree with your partner
about spending priorities get frustrated
with their tendency to save too much
or not enough or harbor resentment about
different income levels
finance and therapy are two things that
have unfortunate stigmas that might
discourage people from getting the help
that could alleviate their problems
we hope that watching us go through this
will make it seem a little less
intimidating for you
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]
you